when I first met my wife I told her I'm
going to make millions of dollars I'm
going to make a lot of money we had our
first date on September 5th and then we
were engaged December 22nd in the Jewish
Community when you get married you sign
a marital document that basically looks
kind of like a prenup called the katuba
and one of the things in there is like
an actual breakup fee if the marriage
breaks up then how much money do you owe
to your wife so my father-in-law sits me
down one day and he's like how much
money do you want to put in the kituba
and I was like I don't care doesn't
matter to me we're not getting divorced
so put $10 million I don't care and he
looks at me and he starts laughing he
goes she's not worth $10 million we'll
put a million doll and um I I frequently
remind him that he is a horrible
negotiator is always the the guy owing
the girl in that document even if the
girls a higher earn yes